[Music]
oMG I feel so bad for international
students right now because nice recently
they just they they have this
announcement thing that says active
students currently the United States
enrolled in such programs must depart
the country or take other measures such
as transferring to a school with
in-person instruction to remain in
lawful status if their school is fully
transitioned to online only so pretty
much what that says is if you are an
international students on a student visa
and your school no longer has in-person
classes like no hybrid or nothing then
you must return to your country which is
so [ __ ] up because there's so many
countries I have a travel ban where they
wouldn't even allow students to come
back in or there's like there's other
countries that are like there's just
like their own turmoil like country
turmoil for example in Ethiopia they
turned off the internet because it was
like civil unrest and so like students
that are from in its that in Ethiopia
they won't even be able to log on to
their online classes because there's
zero internet and I heard that it's like
a month's notice to like they gotta get
out within 30 days I feel like it's out
of nowhere I feel like it's not even to
get people out of the country I think
it's forcing schools to open because
most of the universities most of their
money comes for international students
could they'd have to pay like ten times
the cost like fifty percent is like
international they go to like the big
schools like Caltech or whatever most of
them are international students and they
pay ten times the cost of like someone
who lives in California who pays a
cheaper price yeah so they're saying
that um so recently they contributed
like 1.2 billion dollars to Michigan's
economy in 2008 or 18 2018 international
student international students there
were thirty three thousand two hundred
and thirty six international students
and totalling 1.2 billion dollars from
Michigan's economy alone like just
that's for harbor ambassadors on Supreme
backpacks so you're saying that they did
this so the schools will open up
business like the government's doing
this to force yeah because they don't
saying they want schools to open up
right now Trump is really hard right now
on getting the economy to
like back up again and so Trump has even
recently tweeted that if schools don't
open they will not receive federal
funding which a lot of people are like
you're just [ __ ] bullying because at
that like most schools they get their
funding from States or like from their
own like counties or whatever it's like
from their own like little the state
economy right yeah so it's not even from
federal funding a good chunk of it is
not federal funding so Trump tweeting
that out it's kind of like bullying
schools to to be forced to open like
fully he's just saying ran the [ __ ]
if you don't open up force come on give
me money more I'm not like we never got
money how am I gonna give you money it's
because he doesn't want to be known as a
president that has the shittiest economy
well it's because his reelection is
coming up so he wants to show the voters
or whatever that like hey see we got our
economy back up and we're kicking
that's his campaigning points yeah and
this that's something he did actually
really well before the whole pandemic -
is that a lot of the the economy was
actually on the rise unemployment rates
were like the lowest ever for a long
time so he did that and like the
pandemic along kind of just like
shattered his entire campaign and like
his presidency so so nice willing to
risk people's lives
desperation now exactly I feel like
there's a lot of things happening for
like voting and election prepping for
the election it's kind of sick because
it's like playing with human lives yeah
one of the viewers one of viewers on my
stream came in and said this is really
shitty like we were given like a 48 72
hour notice to get the hell over our
dorms and bring everything with us but
we don't have anymore to go there yeah
yeah where do they go especially if
they're from me out of town I heard
they're not renewing h-1b visas or not
renewing but creating new ones which are
work visas for internationals
and so people who graduated like let's
say they went to school here they've
been living here for like a decade or
whatever for a long time and then they
want to stay in America that's not
happening for a lot of people they have
to they're forced to just go back
because they want whatever jobs are left
to be reserved for American cuz
unemployment is so damn high you know I
think it's another voter tack voting
PACA queer just words like I think both
sides the right and the left don't want
non-citizens here because if citizens
are working then they're happy and
they're they're voting so Harvard
University and MIT are suing the Trump
administration in federal courts they're
seeking to block a this directive that
would strip foreign college students of
their visas if the courses are taken to
online only so they're trying to do
their their best to at least block that
temporarily so international students
have to scramble and be like those fools
science departments are probably like
90% International yeah yeah exactly it's
like a huge percentage they're saying
that like most of our tech science
engineering all of that is it by
Americans it's my China yeah it's by
internationals because our science just
our public school science and all that
is so damn low it's comparable to like a
developing country that all the top
people that are contributing to
technology to this country are
immigrants you can tell it when you go
to college
the science the not even the professor's
yeah the the science students are the
only ones with the roller bags the part
of this global rule of like oh you're
not from here don't pick on roller bag
kids in high school okay they're gonna
grow up to be [ __ ] rich of [ __ ]
[ __ ] the world this is one Vietnamese
guy in my class and like he could barely
speak English and he was destroying an
every single bio test and I'm like what
the [ __ ] I'm like were you like a
straight-a kid back in Vietnam he was
like nah dude I only got C's and stuff
Wow and he's just like America is just
so [ __ ] easy for Mexico to like in
Mexico their math is like way more
advanced really what we do here yeah I
heard that um in like what was it I'll
make you school to like high school it's
actually pretty hard it's super hard in
Asia but college is like a breeze so
it's opposite for us why everyone comes
here for college I guess so maybe they
come
they just straight slaying and [ __ ]
college people so we have a huge
disparity in just public education -
like for example like right here if you
go to San Marino school district that's
probably different or if you go to LAUSD
or like Pasadena School District riot II
yeah yeah or and if you go to a private
school versus like you have alternative
school you have charter school we don't
know where the money is but it's not
like let's say somewhere like Europe
where generally the education is well
Western Europe right like it's generally
the same so someone that has and it's
very mixed as in like if you see their
student body like it's like mixed in in
like wealth and and and culture and
whatever like if you go to school and UK
at least my friends in UK were telling
me generally your experiences are the
same all over versus like an LA imagine
if you go to Beverly Hills High versus
if you go to like Lincoln High right
like yeah completely different life so
student body itself is already like
education alone like it's just like the
student body is a big game-changer in
terms of how you view your school
experience so many of the country's
schools have metal detectors like we do
I angrily knowledge detectors if I know
there's a lot here that has metal
detectors and security guards and
millington thanks for your backpacks
yeah and like dogs come sniff your back
maybe South Africa
I don't know cuz I heard that they're
pretty rough you definitely had dogs in
there we had a dog sniffing dog yeah mom
dogs and drug dogs everywhere the dogs
came once and I was stupid because I had
cigarettes my backpack was like oh my
god they're not trained for that
they're not for that I was an idiot yeah
I don't know it's so crazy for love
international students right now it's
just so much uncertainty and then when
the pandemic first struck and they were
getting forced out of their dorms and of
like they they can't not just not only
for the travel bans in the countries but
even countries that don't have travel
bans but these students they can't even
go back home because they have like
elderly grandparents really or whatever
it is in their home that there
they just can't even risk its going home
right colleges don't you have to pay
first and then now that you're not
having classes they don't even [ __ ]
refund you have a refund I remember
reading something about like there's
students don't like a lawsuit yeah it's
a grip - it's like 30 40 grand for like
a semester or quarter or something
that's I saw a spaceship I mean use the
campus huh that's a lawyer salary from
mm-hmm that's a lot you know speaking of
the UK schools did you know that the
schools there actually have houses like
in Harry Potter you know is house of
Gryffindor shut the [ __ ] up are you
serious yeah so we can have gang wars in
school I saw that in like a tweet and
then everybody was like nah you're
[ __ ] around no no no but turns out
they actually do have houses like like
each what are they divided it sounds
really cool still talk Gryffindor but
yeah yeah they compete and stuff like
that too so like they were like yeah I
guess the uniform is color-coded to
whatever they're still [ __ ] around
with me in that tweet I don't know it's
like returnees but not as future did
your middle schools or your eyes have
like like in sixth grade I remember like
they divided the sixth-grade student
body into gold team blue sapphire team
and emeral team yeah but we had teams
and like that I think it was just easier
to divide the kids up and then each
group had like their own set of teachers
that would teach them oh we have it but
it feels like what you're talking about
the Gryffindor stuff but we didn't you
guys had the colors and everything to
Harry Potter so all the emeralds are all
sleazebags man yes they're all CIOs
outside
no you know it's crazy but like in the
UK they actually have a ton of like
boarding schools like at least because
of the media like movies and TV shows
there's always kids that actually live
in their school they learn a lot in here
they always made it sound shitty bill I
mean you better behave I'll send you to
boarding school here not boarding
schools here I went to boarding school
it's not fun I went to all boy boarding
school for one of my junior years and
you it's like it's a clockwork you gotta
wake up at like six eight no sorry right
yeah and you got to put on a tie and it
would be different if it wasn't military
though my brother went to a coed
boarding school he was in it was a it
was a Christian private school though
but they had a huge property and you can
work on like the farm part of it but
there's also there was also a beach side
so in between classes are like after
school people would just surf so it was
it was just yeah people ride horses and
just it was [ __ ] sick yeah I wanted
to go there I want that for high school
yeah it's it's a it's co-ed I'd be
pissed if I sat down in a chair and the
guy before me just let the [ __ ] kind of
sand in my chair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]